I'm a fellow at the Berkman Klein
Center. Very happy to be here and I'm
originally Swiss but spent the past 18
years in in Asia. I'm looking at AI
and always from China and maybe a larger Asian angles. The research question is
it's partially copy/paste from the 10 or
15 year older question. "What about
the Internet in China and outside?" And
now the question is "What about AI in
China and outside of China?" There's
a lot of a lot of stuff to to be looked
at. AI will have as big an impact
on society. And society always means me
you and the family and everybody around us. Just as the Internet20 years
ago, and over time. It would not be
wise to say the Internet  is not for
me or to say nowadays AI is not for me
because it's going to be around you anyway.
And so from a personal individual
point of view or a company point of view
or even a family point of view, I think
it makes sense to start looking around
and see what's going on. Does it
help you? Does it hurt you? Should
you use it? Should you not use it? Then
once it's clear that you should
use it and how do you use it? What are
the tools, what are the risks for
employees, risk for companies, risk for
kids? I'm always worried about the people
who are not able to enjoy a technology.
I think that scares me because it
creates a even larger gap. You don't only have rich people and
poor people, and you have that divide. But
I think with the rich and the poor you have an
additional divide of using technology or
not using technology or being able and
having the money to use technology will
make the rich richer and the poor
more poor. So that's something that scares me because it
creates tension and we've seen that over
the past 10 or 20 years.